Gregg Java the real rejects um so a new
Yatta Yatta dude my favorite film of all
time despicable - is coming back with
Despicable Me 3 the trailers here's
Steve Carell it's not the office did you
see Despicable Me 2 I did one end - I
had a lot of fun with Despicable Me 2 I
don't remember exactly what happens but
I do know GRU gets married
where's Groot no guru Groot is a DC
Comics character let's not get that
wrong I saw both of these movies yeah
the second one has el macho right I
don't know it's my shoe I'm supposed to
be in it I haven't nothing about this I
didn't realize they're making this
already
that's only they got like the store in
the mall
hahahaha I wish I could do that way
funnier than the dunker trainer reverse
monster monster it's a man wearing
shoulder pads there's only one super
villain whose fashion sense is
immediately closing fast
okay wait Wow what did you call us
brucey you know GRU and Lucy push
together GRU see ha ha I want to get the
nermal on I don't like
[Music]
Wow Wow
[Music]
[Music]
hello looks like a lot of others
hilarious here's the thing about this
big movie movies but I've seen both of
them and even though I'm not like gotta
watch those again real soon like I
remember both times I had a blast like
yeah they're funny they're inventive
yeah and the thing about disfigure with
me that like right when the time it came
along it was refreshing to me because it
was nice like I like Pixar and Disney
and like the stuff that gets you know a
little more emotional about it and even
noting his computer but you know like
a-- and the claymation stuff but it was
nice to go back to Despicable Me and
have it be a cartoon again yeah totally
I missed the cartoon that wasn't like
too obnoxious was so kind of you know
energetic and obnoxious in a good way
and yeah it's a lot of fun that's groove
not a bad guy at all anymore I can't
tell ya I think he's a good guy now cuz
I like that about guru how he just
fancied himself a villain majorly wasn't
yeah this terrible he's good enough in
ingenuity but he's not great at being an
action is gently doer of Deeds whose
Trey Parker again Trey Parker is half of
the South Park team Trey Parker and Matt
Stone so he doesn't much support voices
which that's what I'm excited I in this
I wonder if he's gonna make fun of
himself on South Park for being in this
if this movie sucks he'll do it if this
movie's great he probably won't
I think it'll happen regardless in some
way or another yeah I'm sure it'll come
up but I like the villain yeah he seems
like fun that's it like it this guy
who's like stuck in the 80s yeah yeah
it's fun I this is a fun trend the jokes
I thought were funny in this row yeah
they're really funny you know it's weird
that the trailer like every Despicable
speckle only to when the disease is
Catholic starting in shhh
we have three names listed on this
yeah that was nice I noticed that and I
was like oh like what's cool about this
trailer to me is like we really focused
on grew in the village and this one
particular and primarily this one
specific moment that they cut around
yeah I mean I'm sure it's gonna play out
much longer the theatres but the whole
specific moment of guy evades the ship
bubblegum groom and his wife come in and
I grew encounters him that was a nice
truth that was really funny yeah you
know to call me a curmudgeon but I liked
that it wasn't super minion heavy I
liked that it was about GRU and his
story you know I wonder if the the girls
are gonna be back I'm sure they'll be
here in some capacity because you just
come out now they should just die that
should be the one evil thing crew
finally does the murders is done most
one of the most evil things Boston he
had to prove it to himself he's like
Dominic Toretto and the fate of the
Furious you know would you do it I mean
that moment at the end was like really
ridiculous but I thought it was so funny
you actually see Gru's ass a little bit
it's like pretty revealing for a kid's
movie it's a little bit of gurus ass and
I thought the minion moments were kind
of funny too that she went comes out
together lumination yeah there there is
your relation I get why the world loves
it is I've never seen the minions movie
I feel like that would ruin everything I
feel like the minions movie would ruin I
feel I'd be too much minions no more
minions firm but that was that was a
delight yeah I had a good time
all right reject so for you the channel
subscribe today missed get accepted Jon
his reasons Jared Instagram and Twitter
miss and he is a social media manager
facebook.com slash the real rejects and
he's book.com slash Blum house yes and
shout out to all you really miss that
time subscribe to you guys hey you made
it
subscribe to yourselves cuz then you
might not be real if I want you to our
comments I want everyone commenting and
subscribing to each other in the comment
box yeah everyone subscribe like turn to
the person on your left and subscribe to
their channel it's like the trailer says
hope is a weapon survival
is victory Despicable Me 3 coming out
next time